in this box is the 15-inch animal
crossing tom nook plush
mega stuff in this box is the club mochi
mochi animal crossing tom nook mega
15-inch plush stuffed toy in
this box is the 15-inch
in this box is the club mochi mochi 15
inch animal crossing
tom milk stuffed plush toy this is so
hard this is so hard guys
in this box is the club mochi mochi
animal crossing tom nook
mega 15 inch plush stuffed toy
i think we just go tom look pillow just
tom look pillow
full disclosure i bought this for 29.99
myself with my
own money this was not sent to me for
free so you can trust this is my full
opinion if you guys are just here to
find out where you can get one i
actually purchased mine from amazon.com
for 29.99
i'll include an affiliate link down in
the description below but if you want to
know whether or not this plush toy i
mean
pillow is worth 30 stay tuned because
we're getting into the review of the tom
look pillow right now
first the unboxing okay so we have the
box here this is box from
amazon.com i've already cut it open
let's go ahead and dive in
open it up here okay right here off the
bat
got a nice little uh just a confirmation
also letting me know about returns if i
need to do that
we're not gonna need to do that uh
here's some just cardboard on top
protecting it and
oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen when
they said mega
did they mean mega
there's tom nook's head his giant head
anything else in the box no
nothing all right
box out of the way okay we have this
nice little protective
wrapper here let's go ahead and get that
off
and that is it all right
wow okay first immediate impressions i
gotta say
it is legitimately guys it is
legitimately
very very soft they were not lying about
that in the marketing
promo materials very soft indeed so
there he is tom nook
i mean he they could have gotten a
little happier shot of him but i guess
this will do
we do have this little uh club mochi
mochi
game style
the little tag right here let's see
what's inside shall we
and just just you know all the boring
stuff all right so this is the tomnic
pillow right here
again we're going with tom nick pillow
because that's much easier to say
now let's see i mean it is a pretty good
size
but what i am more curious about is how
it holds up
to the claims on amazon.com so
officially licensed product let's check
that let's verify that guys
i am looking for an official nintendo
seal of quality and i am
not seeing an official nintendo seal of
quality i don't see it oh wait wait wait
wait wait
there it is guys the official nintendo
seal of quality
right there on the back give him a check
mark for that one
super soft i gotta say that was the very
first thing i noticed
got it got to give them the approval on
that as well it is it is 100
super soft and
huggable plush
it is it is huggable i can confirm it is
indeed huggable
features fan favorite characters are you
a fan favorite tom
i don't know what do you guys think is
he a fan favorite or not i mean
yeah we'll give him that we'll give him
that one fan favorite
designed in japan let's see here
uh club mochi mochi made in china okay
they didn't say where it was made of
this this is where it was designed
is what they're promoting on the website
let's see do we have anything in here
about where
it was designed i don't know if we can
give them the approval on this guys i
mean i guess we have to take their word
for it
or do we
collect them all is also a feature i
mean
i can't if you want to collect them all
go for it they also have an isabelle one
also 29.99 on amazon i'll put a link
down there to that one
as well if you're interested and then
finally suitable for ages three and up
i have a six-year-old i have a
two-year-old i think they'd both be
fine with this you know the the one
thing about pills like this is is the
tags
this tag is gonna come off no problem
it'll be interesting to see how much
this one gets in the way i don't think
it would get a win
in the way too bad but the thing you
always have to worry about is when you
cut these tags
then like where you cut it it's always
kind of poking you and annoying you even
more
so i think i'm just going to remove this
one and i'll leave these on and we'll
try that out for a while
uh you know i mean maybe we'll see i
might i mean maybe we can get a good
night's sleep on this
give me your bells give me your bells
all of them would you like another house
loan boy would you like another house
loan
you may have also seen their products
before at places like target and amazon
this is actually my first mochimoji
product club mochi mochi also has an
isabelle plush toy i mean
pillow whatever you want to call it now
the most important question here
is it worth thirty dollars look i'm not
gonna lie to you thirty dollars
a little expensive for a pillow i feel
like twenty would be a really solid
price point
if you got the cash to spare and you're
a really big animal crossing fan then
sure go for it 30 bucks
but if you want to wait i think you
could probably get this on a little bit
of a deal maybe see it as low as 20
it is a new product so who knows how
long that will take i also saw that
there are a bunch of other tomnic
pillows
on amazon for some reason whenever you
search tom nook pillow i couldn't get
this one to pop up i don't know if it
just takes a couple days to populate by
the time you're watching this
it may pop up when you do that but i
gotta say it is officially licensed by
nintendo and it is definitely very soft
i gotta give them credit for that in
fact i might use this to lay down on my
little
gaming couch over here instead of my
other pillows they're kind of rough the
pillowcase around them but this one very
very soft
so for the animal crossing fans out
there if you got a gaming room
it would really look great if this your
first time here we've got a lot of other
animal crossing videos for you you can
see them
here on the right side of your page
right now we've got things for beginners
for animal crossing new horizons and
also things for the more
experienced players and if you guys
would like to see more animal crossing
videos like this
reviews of tom nook pillows and other
bizarre
animal crossing products then hit that
subscribe button
give me a thumbs up before you go in the
meantime
i'm gonna go and hug my tomnic pillow he
is
very very huggable so soft
so soft tom